more proof that no one is safe when it
comes to the crime crisis in america
even our children shocking surveillance
video showing career criminal thug this
punk previously arrested over 40 times
sucker punching get this a four-year-old
in the middle of times square a block
from here his mother's mama bear
instincts kicking in immediately
tackling the perp to the ground until
police arrive to arrest him nypd officer
saying who needs d.a bragg a reference
to the liberal new d.a here in manhattan
county the mother took care of justice
the detective said the old-fashioned way
here's how she described the scene
i turned around and the baby's screaming
and crying and i said what happened she
my daughter said that guy right there
hit him i grabbed him and i fell on my
back
with him on top of me and he was kicking
i don't think that he shouldn't even be
out
and we just want to start with the
ladies uh you know emily uh i don't know
if you take the subway
oh let me talk
let me before i get to emily uh this
whole scenario is happening as at least
eight people were attacked in new york
city's subway system over the weekend
after the mayor here eric adams the new
mayor announced a new safety plan to
crack down on subway crime i also want
to mention that chicago which has
already suffered at least seven murders
chicago has suffered seven murders since
friday since friday we still have all
day today the holiday weekend so now you
take subways and
are you afraid um not actually i don't
anymore even you guys i walk to and from
work in the snow because i don't want to
risk it i i have the luxury that i don't
have to take the subway not everyone
does uh part of this plan here in this
state it includes an expansion of
kendra's law which was a 1999 statute
that allows judges to force um
outpatient treatment for mentally ill
people and my point is that the reason
that a lot of these laws are on the
books is because of a horrific event a
tragedy someone's life that was taken
that resulted in the law being passed to
prevent those kinds of horrible
tragedies from happening in the future
and what we've seen is a complete
erosion of it so we didn't touch on the
intro but i'm sure everyone has heard
about that a maniac child molester in
los angeles that was heard gloating over
the phone well the issue there was that
the d.a because he prosecuted him at
that time
as a juvenile
made the judge unable to do anything the
judge quoted as saying my hands are tied
and the judge said or the d.a said now
released a statement to fox news and
said well the level of remorse about the
harm that she caused the child like if i
had known more i would have handled
things differently but the facts the
facts are what conveyed that they don't
need a level of remorse to tell a da
what they need i need a da to do their
job the kids that don't have a mom that
can attack the perp at that moment
they're relying on the d.a to prosecute
based on laws that are in place based on
prior tragedies to ensure they don't
happen again that has all been eroded
thanks to democrats you know cleveland
this weekend we had the all-star game
nba all-star game it's gonna be my one
more thing today but uh my pal the
detective steve loomis he wrote me and
said they just closed another rite aid
this is where i get my meds in old
brooklyn as part of cleveland i closed
because of shoplifters gone wild with no
enforcement prosecution or consequence
my once nice safe neighborhood has gone
to shat uh
while the politicians sat back and
watched two murders yesterday in
cleveland during all-star weekend yeah i
blocked to work the other day and
they're posting nypd officers outside of
walgreens think about what other things
they could be doing besides posting up
outside of a pharmacy what a waste of
time but you got to do it because things
are out of control and you talk about
politicians sitting back and watching
you have a democrat d.a democrat mayor
democrats control the nypd they control
the federal prosecutor here
state legislator two democrat senators
by the way has check schumer said a damn
thing yeah
where has been chuck where is aoc where
is he going to see about any of this
stuff remember they're stealing baby
formula that's the issue so when someone
walks through times square and clocks a
young kid like that i would be
embarrassed as a democrat in new york to
have to watch moms come out and and
tackle this guy until cops arrive guy
never should have been out on the street
like this you have 125 000 either
tourists or citizens come through
times square every single day haralda
that's two
football stadiums worth of people and it
is the center of the world
biggest you know
urban nexus in the entire world and it
is the democrats responsibility to keep
this place safe and not only had little
kids getting their clocks and you've had
rapes you've had you've had shootings
you've had stabbings
you've had homicides in times square
this cannot happen in a city like this
and the politicians have to stop blaming
guns and republicans and kovid and blame
themselves i i think that one thing i
remember from the old days dana the uh
guardian angels were everywhere yeah in
the subways particularly uh maybe
citizens have to fight back maybe maybe
that the old days yeah just come again
a moment
their kid
oh their mom is going to practice but
they shouldn't have to they shouldn't
have to and i think that um think about
the fact that there's crime happening
all across the country the next step in
the process in san francisco is for
chessa boudin the liberal prosecutor
there he's up for a recall on june 7th
might not turn out the same way as the
school board because the george soros
money might be a little bit different in
this case but all eyes should be on that
the last thing i would say is we were
going to have this guest on newsroom
this morning whose nine-year-old
daughter i think was caught in the
crossfire
she never should have been shot but she
was so babies are being hit they're
being raped and they are being um killed
sometimes it's mistaken identity
sometimes it's because of a road rage
incident but that is the kind of thing
where you see that like the social
fabric really starts to crumble and you
think about it president biden came to
new york a few weeks ago to have his
picture taken with mayor adams and mayor
adams there's a lot of good will for him
but it's about to be march first and
this stuff is not at all looking like
it's going to get better do you despair
joey
listen if i have a three-year-old
daughter if that happens to my daughter
the only person going to jail is me
because i'm putting you in the grave and
sending your soul straight to hell
that's all yeah i like that
when we go to war and we lose limbs and
we lose our brothers and our sisters we
do it to protect the innocents in this
country first and foremost
so it really pisses me off to not let to
see our politicians not do the same
thing all you have to do is put a little
bit of career collateral out there to
put bad people in jail when there's a
whole class of americans willing to die
to do the same thing just to protect
these innocent people starting with our
kids and it goes into the mass mandates
in schools in all the ways that we're
letting people harm our kids for no good
reason other than we're mad at each
other i'm honored to sit at this table
with you hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else